in this video we're going to go back to
school and we're going to cover some of
the basic terminology of email
some of this may be very familiar to you
some of it will be new
let's get started and talk about the
most basic element of email and that's
the list
whenever you hear email marketers talk
they're going to be referring to the
list and simply the list is the list of
email addresses that you have
this list can be broken up in many ways
but ultimately the list is your
customers your prospects
anyone who has said they want to receive
an email from you
ultimately the list is the group of
people you are going to email
now you can grow your list by collecting
email addresses
the majority of companies collect the
email address from a transaction on the
website
they can come from many other methods
but just gathering those names from your
website from people that say they want
to hear more from you or they want to
receive information is the primary way
of building that
now the email server is very much like
the post office of email
it routes the email from your computer
to the intended destination
and so it's essentially taking your
email
routing it through the server
to go to the person that you are sending
that email
and so it can be your business or
internal server that you have inside
your company
it can be a third-party service such as
a godaddy or rackspace
or you can be using
a third-party email service
such as constant contact mailchimp some
of those that will take care of your
email marketing list
and will be that third-party go-between
for sending out a mass amount of email
to different people
and that third party handles all of the
legalities and the sending options for
that
so an esp is an email service provider
they are the ones that can handle and
maintain your list as well as enable you
to build an email through their service
and send it to those people and the
email service provider will enable
better management of your list
now one of the methodologies of sending
email
that is called a batch and blast
is taking the same email message
and sending it to everybody on the list
typically this is done with a newsletter
or a company update
and what it does is it assumes that
everyone is interested in this message
so that's why we call it the batch and
blast we're taking all the names that we
have and we're sending them the exact
same email
now sometimes for best practices
we tend to back off of this approach
because we've found that targeted emails
tend to work better
but batch and blast is just sort of an
offhanded way of saying we're sending
the same newsletter or the same
communication to everybody we have on
that list
now how you build your list is very
important
how people have
let you know that they want to receive
an email message is critical
and so an opt-in is when someone allows
you and gives you permission to send
them an email
an opt-in is one of those very critical
factors that helps establish your
company as following best practices in
email marketing
and opt out
is where you allow people to say i don't
want to receive email from you
and so it requires action on the part
of the recipient to say i no longer want
to receive
email from you
in a lot of laws require opt-outs to be
part of mass mailings so that a
recipient can opt out of future mailings
at any time
an opt-out can also be called an
unsubscribe
where they can go in and say i no longer
want to receive email messages from you
as a company
or i just want to unsubscribe from this
list
and so giving people the ability to
manage their own email contact settings
is something that allows you to comply
to spam laws but also gives your
customer
additional ability to manage their
contact preferences
now i've mentioned the word spam
numerous times but chances are you know
what that is
spam is anything that you receive that's
unsolicited or unsubscribed
if you've never subscribed to receive
email from a specific vendor or a person
or an organization and it shows up in
your email box anyway
that's considered spam
there are incredibly powerful spam
filters on email servers everywhere
and so you need to make sure that you
are abiding by best practices and spam
laws
in order for your email not to be
considered spam
in talking about spam what
differentiates different types of
messages is the understanding of what
makes a transactional email
if someone is purchasing from you if
they've requested information
if they're looking for a download that
is a transaction
they have received value for giving you
their email address
and that determines moving forward if
they are receiving spam or if they have
opted in to receive email messages from
you
now a blacklist
is something that you do not want your
company to be on
a blacklist is set aside by email
servers as a gateway to preventing
people who have repeatedly abused email
by sending spam by sending unsolicited
email to other people
and so the blacklist limits
the ability
of those organizations or those mail
sources to send unsolicited email
the open rate is how many people opened
your email to view it the first
measurement that people typically look
at when it comes to email marketing is
the open rate
and it's also the first trap that they
can fall into
they tend to view open rates as the
primary indicator of success of an email
marketing campaign but unfortunately
open rate doesn't tell the full story
and
it's more of a fuzzy number because not
all email clients
report the open rate the same it's very
undependable
and so really just use the open rate as
a guide
rather than focusing on it as a measure
of success
a click-through is much more of a hard
measurement of how people interacted
with your email
so whereas we can look at the number of
opens and get an idea of how many people
looked the click tells us how many
people took an action to click through
the email to the landing page that we
have set up for that destination and so
it's much more of a hard number to look
at success of an email campaign
now the email client is whatever your
target recipient uses to view email it
could be outlook it could be macmail
it's whatever they use in order to open
the email that's the email client
now there's also what's called free mail
and that's any free email service such
as gmail or yahoo mail or hotmail
their web-based email accounts which act
a little bit differently than corporate
email accounts or other types of email
accounts
and so that's going to come in when we
look at deliverability and how your
message appears
to the recipient
this has been an overview of email
marketing terminology and i look forward
to digging more into the email
foundations series